Wow that was a great reaction you guys  [Applause]  so much to talk about  I mean what a week you're having Oh May  you're the cover of Entertainment Weekly  yes'm and it's just incredible I mean  your show is still going up through the  roof and then this explosion of grief on  social media about what happened to your  character Glenn yeah I feel dead in real  life would ya good or bad that would be  bad yeah you can take that both ways  there's a good side to I don't have to  pay for stuff but I do get to come here  and talk to you about it right take it  from us if you're feeling dead this is  I'm just curious like what's that what's  been an emotional moment for you when  you shot the scene it must have been  very intense it it was pretty it was  pretty bad you know watching all your  friends cry and go through it but I got  to I got to bug my eye out so that was I  know that was pretty cool that was  pretty cool yeah that was very cool  you